you guys in this section first hello
what would you like a rap about
Nietzsche on a boat thank you very much
sir as if freestyle rapping about
Friedrich Nietzsche wasn't hard enough
he's he's at sea or is he at C is he on
a lake or a river where where it could
be a steamboat does does that affect the
body of water
okay a river a Steamboat's only allowed
on rivers
somebody you you think someone over
there went yes I lost my entire family
Chris
due to some unwise seaworthiness of
calls
Friedrich Nietzsche on a steamboat well
let's let's bounce to this side room
seeing as this is the you know the
nautical safety side of the venue what
would this side of the room like a
rapper
[Music]
your shitty Vespa I mean
[Applause]
I mean no one liked that one at all they
were everyone was there with the passion
for my shitty Vespa
um that it was spoken as if that is a
true a true feeling you have in your
heart your [__] for those of you that
don't know of a Vesper is an Italian
brand of scooter am I correct yes okay
cool okay you you are really the
authority of everything over there just
one man correct
um and and Tim Cook at Disneyland a good
suggestion but I guess not for tonight
it's Vespers from that side middle of
the room will take we'll take two from
the middle because it's the kind of the
Louisiana Purchase lovely stuff thank
you very much so that's the the process
by which America bought the land owned
by France I guess when when would that
have happened then would that
post-independence up because we don't
learn anything about your country
1776 on we don't we don't
we in history lessons it's like it just
stops
I was like what happened then sir and
he's like none of your concerned
the person who knows about steamboats
and Vespers did you just say 1828 is
that can anyone verify that that's true
1803 wow you took your shot but I like
it
the Louisiana Purchase in 1803 it is a
lot of history well let's get let's get
a second one from the South Pole thank
you very much that's pretty simple we
don't need to ask what that is or where
it is it's in the name back of the room
hello
I heard something right
shark bites in Portugal delightful thank
you very much why not why not well this
is this is what you've selected um
before we recap them we should invite
the band back on stage if you a round of
applause for the
exceptionally talented band it's all
right Jake what's the what's the tattoo
of on your arm it's it's of a man with
pancakes on his head yeah
caps caps for sale
[Music]
a reference that has gone by me and I
would ask that man but there's not
enough time well this
also you really lost your credibility
with the 1828 thing when several more
people knew it was 1803 so nature on a
steamboat we have the Louisiana Purchase
of 1803 my shitty Vespa the uh the South
Pole and Portuguese shark by shark bites
in Portugal sorry the nationality or
ethnicity of the Sharks was not
clarified
[Applause]
okay well I mean Mark is going to start
a beat um we have not done a sound check
or rehearsal so this is going to be as
improvised for them as it is for me I
hope you're excited you're excited are
you excited
and we'll start with the back
[Music]
clarified fish ethnicity I'll report you
all if I flip it back agree hanging out
in Portugal maybe on the coast yeah it's
on I'm seeing football teams green and
white in Lisbon they'd be sporting SCP
ever when you take a little wave in the
deep blue
Jackson Remember in deep blue sea and
the shark cracked on his waist it was a
real twist spoiler alert fighting there
on my wrist and you know it hurts I try
and Shake It Off and rip out its moles
but can't keep coming back the jaw they
just roll there it's basically five six
or seven Rolls for Portuguese desserts
yes I chose the little flambe custard I
take and throw it out any shark any
Fisher snake that's hanging there in the
sea
[Music]
200 years ago-ish 1828 but several
people they disagree their life now is
220 1803 you heard this absurd of
Louisiana Purchase the French they were
like we will we've heard it's a great
deal for King Louise people say you're
getting stiffed balls that's for weed
why would we want States Over the Sea
give it to Americans there's 15
eventually I mean not as a times the
whole American West didn't have the time
to find an [__] crime and rolls
errands in number Louisiana actually
[Music]
I know he was obviously observing he
never visited in his life his whole goal
the Arctic [__] that I'm about the South
Pole I don't want the Bears I'm going to
the Penguins call down there but start
your engines Norwegians they were the
first to explore going down there seeing
more and more than you ever saw what an
incredible place they were moving around
here really having a race one was on a
dog sled running with the Huskies but
then one of the guy he's kind of trusty
he's there on a small helmet in letters
he says this whole jacket pulls the
outfit together on his Vespa don't
second guess you're coming from Italy
still where's the fueling stations down
in the South there's hardly any land
mass he's got his heart in his mouth
this guy he says I got it from Italy
sadly the mechanical Integrity is shitty
I'm struggling I ride it in Brooklyn
people look at me I think I'm good
looking cause it's catchy I look like a
60s mod but sadly it doesn't work I feel
like a sword all the city bikes they can
overtake me the Vesper oh my God it's a
fake scene they just put an electric
motor in something like 15 vhd doesn't
keep you jumping there we go that's the
wrap flowing there off the hook and
finish with Disneyland shout out Tim
Cook
Give It Up
game over
[Applause]